Hi there.
Licensee,
Deutsche,
Deutsche.
No,
sorry,
I don't speak Dutch.
Hello language,
enthusiastic.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about the German
language.
German is a very important language that
deserves all of our attention.
It is spoken by $95 million native
speakers mainly in central Europe,
but it's also spoken by an additional 10
to $15 million second language speakers,
especially in eastern Europe.
It is the majority language and an
official language in Germany of course,
but also Austria,
Switzerland,
Liechtenstein and the south tyrol region
of northern Italy.
It's also an official language in
Luxembourg and Belgium,
but it's not a majority language there.
German is the most widely spoken
language in the European Union.
It is also one of the most widely taught
languages in the world with between 75
and 100 million people.
Having studied it as a foreign language
in both the United States and in Europe,
it is the third most widely taught
foreign language.
Did you know that one 10th of the
world's books are published in German.
German is also the second most widely
used scientific language.
I know some doctors and all of them have
some reading knowledge of German because
so much scientific research has
documented in German,
so are you starting to get an idea of
why German is important?
German is a member of the West Germanic
language family,
which also includes Dutch,
Africans,
Friesian,
English and Yiddish.
The West Germanic languages are part of
the wider Germanic language family.
So let's take a look at the origins of
the dramatic language family.
Wait,
actually no,
I did this in my last video,
so I'm just going to play that part
again while I go get a coffee and I'll
be right back.
All Germanic languages developed from
Provo Germanic,
which was spoken around 500 bce.
Protoje dramatic possibly originated in
Scandinavia,
and different varieties of Germanic
began to emerge with migration.
Runic inscriptions from the second
century ce show us that by that time,
pro dramatic had began to separate into
distinct western,
eastern and northern dialects.
Oh,
sorry.
Are you guys waiting for me?
Well,
let's move on.
The West dramatic dialects were probably
closely related enough to be mutually
intelligible until about the eighth
century ce,
but at that time something was happening
that would split their dramatic language
family and give birth to the German
language as we know it today.
That was the hydromatic sounds shift or
the hydromatic continental shift.
Some west Germanic varieties underwent a
number of sound changes,
nine consonants changed to be precise
and this created two distinct groups of
Germanic dialect,
high German or Deutsche and low German
or plot doidge and just out of interest,
let me pronounce these words a different
way.
High Deutsche and flat,
which maybe there's a connection with
English high German dialects arose in
the southern areas of Germany which are
at a higher elevation.
That's why they're called hydrogen.
The low German dialects existed in the
northern part of Germany at a lower
elevation and also in the Netherlands.
These terms do not refer to high end low
status,
but rather to the elevation of the areas
they were spoken in,
hydrogen can be further subdivided into
two segments,
upper German and central German.
So what were the sound changes that took
place?
Well,
let's take a look.
These consonant changes took place in
three stages.
In the first stage,
these consonants changed.
Interval calendly,
that means between vowel sounds,
the p sound that became a foot,
this to sound became a sub,
and the sound became a cup.
Here's an example for the English word.
For Sleep.
In Low German it's sloppy,
but in German it's in the second stage.
These continents changed at the
beginning of a word and also in some
other context,
like if they are the second letter in a
double consonant or after an l or an r
sound book became per foot like a p and
an f.
together the sound became a son.
It sounds like a ts sound even though
it's written with a z and the sound
became a like a k sound followed by cup.
Here's an example for the English word
Tame.
In lower German it's tem,
but in high German it's,
I'm in the third stage.
Three more consonants changed.
The book sound became a Po that the
sound became a ta in the sound became a
CCO.
Here's an example for the English word
for day in lower German,
it's f,
but in high German it's talk.
Now all of these sound changes took
place in upper German,
in the south,
but some of them didn't take place in
central German and some of them didn't
take place in standard German,
but we'll get to standard German in a
minute.
So some of you might be thinking,
well,
how did these sounds just switch.
Well,
they didn't instantly switch.
They gradually changed over a period of
a few centuries,
probably between the fifth century and
18th century ce over the centuries,
the dialect continuum of low German had
high German grew more and more distinct
until there were varieties that were
quite incomprehensible,
so someone from the south in Bavaria
would have trouble communicating with
someone from Hamburg in the north.
But of course that was before standard
German.
The dialects of low German are often
said to be a separate language from high
German and there are often sent to be
halfway between high German and Dutch.
Now the low German dialect actually
crosses the border into the eastern part
of the Netherlands where low German has
also spoken,
but these days the low German dialects
in the north of the country are mostly
fading and basically only older people
speak them.
Younger people might understand them,
but they tend to use standard German
instead,
but when did standard German come into
the picture?
Standard German,
which by the way is also called
Hochdeutsch in German,
so don't be confused between hydrogen
and standard German,
originated as a written literary
language that developed over a few
hundred years as writers tried to write
in a way that would be understood by the
largest number of people possible from
different dialect areas,
but perhaps the most important factor in
the development of standard German was
the translation of the Bible into German
by Martin Luther in the year 15,
22.
He based his translation on the sex in
dialect of central German,
while including some vocabulary from
other dialects as well.
Virtually all speakers of German
dialects owned a copy of the new Bible
and studied it effectively popularizing
this form of written German.
Originally there was no single way to
pronounce this written form of German,
but eventually the dialect of Hanover
became the standard for pronunciation of
standard German.
Standard German includes some of the
sounds of the High German continental
shift,
but not all of them because it was
influenced by the dialect of Hanover,
so standard German began as a written
language,
but as it became the language of
education,
it became more widespread as the formal
spoken language and it also influenced
the local dialects.
Today,
pretty much everyone can speak standard
German,
even if they speak a local dialect
casually and many local dialects have
become largely replaced by standard
German,
especially the low German dialects in
the north of the country,
but there are still some dialects that
are quite distinct and still thriving
like the Bavarian dialect in the South
East German is considered a plurry
centric language.
That means that there are multiple
standard varieties of the language.
There is one standard language in
Germany,
one in Australia and one in Switzerland.
All of these standard varieties are
pretty much the same except for some
differing vocabulary,
but of course those are the standard
language of Switzerland and Austria and
also south to roll,
which is related to Austria,
have their own dialects as well.
The Austrian dialects or related to the
Bavarian dialects in South East Germany
and the Swiss dialects are related to
the element of dialects in southwest
Germany.
Maybe you saw my video about the
languages of Switzerland.
It's this one right here and in that
video I talked about how the Swiss
German dialects are kind of
incomprehensible to speakers of standard
German unless they also speak in dialect
from the border area,
but of course that's talking about the
Swiss German dialects.
Swiss Germans can speak standard German
even if they tend to use it less than
people in Germany.
Of course they might pronounce standard
German with a different accent,
but that's no big deal in Austria and
south to roll.
The situation is similar.
There are dialects that might be hard to
understand for people from some other
German speaking countries,
but of course standard German is the
bridge.
These countries are all part of the
German sprocket,
Rome.
Wow.
So which means the geographic area over
which that language is spoken,
and within that sprocket round standard
German is the doc sprocket.
That profit,
that means the umbrella language under
which all of those dialects can come
together.
Those two German terms I just used brock
and are common linguistic terms and I
think that shows just how much influence
the German language has over academic
areas of research like linguistics.
So what is the German language like?
Well,
it's closely related to English,
which is obvious when we look at the
most basic sentences.
Here's an example.
I buy books often.
It's cold for whole fish booster.
Each cow,
Hoy who shot
hear the word order is Svo,
like in English,
except that the adverb comes before the
object instead of after it.
Here's another example with an important
twist.
I will buy the book today.
You've added a spool quite often each
voucher,
just calvin.
In this case,
we see one of the most confusing things
for learners of German,
which is the placement of the second
verb at the end of the sentence.
So if there's a helping verb like will
or voucher,
it is in the normal Svo position,
but the main verb goes at the end.
Another example,
the book was interesting
just via to the sun does va into the
sand.
And one more example,
I like people who work hard
ish.
Mark mentioned to your hot button issue,
mark mentioned the heart operation.
Another thing that learners have German
find challenging is the case system in
German,
in German pronouns and nouns changed
form depending on their function in the
sentence,
but along with them,
the articles and adjectives also change.
Here's an example of German grammatical
cases using the now meaning table,
the acting dean,
Trish just deem Tisha did.
Tisha,
yeah,
sure.
You can see that the change takes place
not only in the noun but also in the
definite article as well.
The word for table is a masculine nouns
in German,
but there are actually three genders in
German.
There are masculine nouns,
feminine nouns and Neuter Nouns,
and for each of them,
the case forms are different,
and all of these different forms also
apply to adjectives which drives
learners crazy.
So while German is closely related to
English,
the devil is in the details,
even though most of the other Germanic
languages are classified as category
one.
Languages by the Fsi,
German is classified as category two,
it's closely related to English and they
have a lot in common in terms of the
general syntax and vocabulary,
but when it comes to the fine details of
grammar,
there are some challenges for learners,
but as always,
if you are interested in German speaking
cultures and countries,
or if you would like to benefit from the
widespread use of German,
then don't hesitate to start learning.
All challenges become adventures when
you become fascinated.
The question of the day German speakers,
do you think there's anything unique or
special or interesting about your local
variety of German and how do other
varieties of German sound to you?
Let us know in the comments down below
and everyone else jump in and let's
discuss.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.